[Music]
hey there and welcome to part three in
this training series and what I'm
calling idea to execution in motion
design my name's Cameron I'm the guy
behind motion science and if you haven't
seen parts 1 & 2 of this training series
I'm going to tell you right now stop
this video go back and watch part 1 and
then watch part 2 before you watch this
third part in series so that you can
really understand how we got to this
point because that's very important I
show you how to create basic design and
then we kind of refine that design we
add some motion and here we are in part
3 and we're gonna really add some polish
this is what I'm I call it polish
because we come in and we add some
finishing elements and we bring it all
together and we make it look awesome
so that's where we're at if you don't
know who I am like I said my name is
Cameron I'm the guy behind motion
science I have been doing motion design
since around 2000
I sometimes 1999 I say sometimes 2001
but or 2002 but in around 99 2000 I
started learning motion design I'm
self-taught I didn't go to college I
just kind of came about motion graphics
by chance a buddy of mine had shown it
to me
I was really intrigued by it so I
started teaching myself everything I
could about motion graphics and I've
been doing it ever since so for 19 20
years now two decades I've been doing
motion graphics and I absolutely love it
what I have learned because I'm
self-taught is that I have a different
way of doing things than what I see a
lot of other motion designers are doing
now because I've been freelancing
professionally since 2007 I've also
gotten to work with a lot of high-end
motion designers and working with them
I've also learned like what their
workflows and what their techniques are
I've taught them mine and you know
learning with how they work and how I
work and kind of combining those things
I've come
with a lot of like I said different
workflows and techniques that are
simplified that work right it's like you
don't always have to have the most
complicated workflow which I've seen
over and over again to make something
look amazing you don't have to have a
complicated workflow you can have a very
simple workflow and make it look awesome
so I've also been hired as a freelancer
to take very complicated projects that
are a complete mess that one or more
teams have worked on and it's my job to
take him and simplify them and make them
look right or look good in the end and
I've gotten very good at that as well so
like I said over the years you know I
started at a very small TV station which
is where I it was I was doing car
commercials and pawn shop commercials
but then I started as a director and
cameraman and producer and started
learning after effects and motion
graphics and design and before I knew it
in 2007 I was working for companies like
prologue and world famous and digital
kitchen and companies that were asking
me to do high-profile projects for shows
that were on HBO and MTV and Sony and
row career I mean the lid I have a lot
of clients I've worked with and I'm not
going on to say that oh you know I'm the
I have some a great class I'm the best
but I am really good at what I do
and I know that and it shows from the
clients who hire me and the work that I
get and the work that I produce so
that's why I'm here I created motion
science to train you as a motion
designer how do you better your craft
and that's what we're doing today so
like I said in the last two videos I
showed you in the first one how to kind
of bring a rough we call it the rough
draft kind of bringing elements into our
After Effects timeline I like to design
an After Effects now sometimes I do
design in Photoshop if I have to do a
lot of cutting out of elements or things
like that I'll start in Photoshop but
then I always bring it back in After
Effects to add my effects and my final
techniques to really bring about the
design and I finish in After Effects and
that's with animation that's also with
design even if I'm doing things like
style frames so I showed you in the
rough draft how I kind of start that was
part one part two was refining in motion
which we added some very simple motion
and we added some some unique elements
here's part three this is called the
polish I am going to move through this
quickly like I've moved through the
other two and I'll probably leave a few
parts out that maybe I would do in a
final polish but I don't have time for
all of that today so with that being
said let's just dive in and get started
the first thing I want to do is it's
been a few days since I've looked at
this and a lot of times I'll just go
back and I'll play through it and I'll
just kind of take a look at how things
are going so I turned off the audio so
I'll play back here and I just kind of
watch it see how things are working if
things aren't working it's always good
to have fresh eyes on a project if
you're able to step away from a project
for a few days even one day we get so
attached to the project that it's hard
to see if it's working or not working if
we've been watching it over and over and
over again
so looking at this there are some things
that would maybe change the camera
movement works for this but you know I
might actually change it a little bit if
I had more time but I don't so let's
just move forward let's start by adding
just a little bit more motion which is
just to the typography here and I love
using the application called animation
composer which if you've seen him other
videos you've seen that I talked a lot
about it's one of my favorite things to
use but I'm not going to use that for
this I'm gonna use decoder Faden which
is a preset that comes inside of After
Effects and I added it there I'm gonna
hit you oh my keyboard I've got the
keyframes here that popped up and all it
does is just kind of does a really
simple decoder fade in like that right
now we don't have to jump into a scene
and start from zero for any animation
right now we do do that for this sacred
geometry in the background and that's
okay for this example but I want
something on here to begin with so I'm
actually going to back this up and have
my type already coming on the screen and
there are finishes so we get plenty of
time to read it
I'll go here to Gina black I'll select
I'll go back into animation presets to
code or fade in there we go again and
the keyframes are way off screen here so
I'm going to bring them in again we
don't have to start at zero where so
let's just start with let's just have
Gina on screen to start so there we go
okay and we want to come you know come
on pretty quick so we have time to read
it and then Toby's gonna be the same way
we're going to select toby recent
presets decoder fade in at you to pull
up the keys i'm selecting start so it
selects all the keys because i have a
key way off screen here i'm gonna bring
it in and then bring the start key up
here and this one we have a little bit
more time to read so I may just you know
let's do something like this again start
with almost toby being on-screen yeah
that works okay cool so the next i'm
going to do is i want to add some like
some just a few glitchy elements to this
lots of ways you can do glitch but i'm
just gonna add a new adjustment layer
and I'm gonna hit the turns call this
glitch and I'm just gonna start all
times I like to start it's almost like
it's a transition element right it's a
glitch that comes in so it's going to
help us transition between this first
shot here and this shot here and it
doesn't need to be long so I'll hit
option bracket to cut it off there and a
simple way to do glitch is just go to
distort displacement matter
and it's on there and I'm just gonna
reference itself that's fine
zero actually let's make this be a real
high vertical glitch so something like
this which is really kind of crazy I'll
need a mess with any of that so it's
just really fast if I preview this so
you can see there so it just helps
transition it pulls the frame down
really quickly and a lot of times I will
actually listen to the audio to get the
find out where I want the transitions to
be but I want to space them out a little
bit so maybe here you know if I turn
this off yeah you can see there so it's
got a totally different vibe to it for
this so maybe something like that let's
just try that and it's go ahead and
bring it above spotlight and maybe again
right in here
but for this one let's actually turn
this crank the horizontal up and the
vertical to zero and you know this this
particular shot moves right to left so
that's kind of interesting there and we
can mess with things like luminance see
that's gonna change anything you
actually takes it the opposite way yeah
so this back
you know what it's doing it's
referencing layer six that's why it's
looking a little bit strange so I'm
going to reference itself and let's just
change this back to red there we go
and let's change this one back to itself
which is layer three and I'll probably
just preview this and see how it's
looking yeah so really simple but it
works right and coming back to this
first shot here I actually want to see
now that I'm looking at sacred geo I
want it to come start a little bit on
the screen there so we'll just do
something like that
cool
okay so next let's add a flicker effect
above everything and easier way to do
that a lot of ways you can do that I
will just add a let's do like a white
solid not a hundred percent white me
well somewhere in there and we'll call
this flicker and there we go let's drop
the opacity to like fifteen percent and
let's add a wiggle expression an altar
option click you were gonna say wiggle
[Music]
let's have it be pretty intense so let's
just try sixty sixty maybe too much okay
so there it goes pretty intense one
thing I might try and do is just bring
the flicker down below the glitch just
to see if it changes anything not really
bring this how that was okay that was
why so we'll take this one let's take a
look at this mmm actually I have to
flick her above the glitches but it is
really intense so the first one is the
frequency the second one is the
amplitude let's change the amplitude
down to maybe 20 let's see how this
looks
and actually liked it better the first
way but maybe let's turn the opacity
down to zero let me just see what this
does
okay so that works okay for me the
flicker is very intense but I think I
can bring it down a little bit when I
add some of the final effects here one
other thing I want to add here is I want
to add another adjustment layer and
we're gonna call this wave warp and I
did not spell it right but that's okay
distort and when you wave warp and let's
see here when trying to square and
really bit 10500 like this zero and the
wave speed will be negative one so it's
a very slow moving effect and then we're
gonna go and we're gonna add a keyframe
here at the beginning one percent right
click toggle hold keyframe okay because
and I'm doing this because I don't want
so you can see if you look up in here
you can see the effect happening I'll
just preview this just this first part
but you see this line that kind of comes
through here that's the wave warp that
we're adding so it's just some more
distortion type of effects that are
going on so I have it set to a hundred
percent it's an adjustment layer so it's
on and then I want to see it I don't
necessarily want to see it when the text
comes on here so I'm going to set it to
zero so it pops off there and then when
we have the camera do its move again not
that one when we have this camera do its
move we will pop it back on and then
we'll go through here it can stay on for
this that's just fine we'll pop it back
off again here and we'll leave it on
here and maybe have it kind of
come on here yeah I think that works so
let's take a look at this
yeah just to add some visual interest
there okay so we're starting to get
close now so I want to add another
adjustment layer and I love adjustment
layers it's a great way it's an easy way
to add of effects to everything below of
the adjustment layer so if you don't
know what adjustment layers are
definitely recommend that you check them
out and just kind of get understanding
but essentially it's just a layer you
can apply effects to or different things
to that a layer and it'll affect
everything below it so this I'm going to
I'm gonna add something called duotone
now normally I'm a huge fan of sapphire
and I use sapphire on every single
project
I should caveat that with 95 99 percent
of all projects I use sapphire on it in
some way so something like this I would
probably use like s duotone which
where's it add I don't know it's in here
do it on there it is I would probably
use this effect not with these colors
but I know a lot of you don't have
sapphire so if you don't have it you can
go to color correction you can go to
something called CC toner and we can
change it from tritone to duo tone and I
just want to make this thing like this
crazy-looking red like almost like this
really dark red color so the biggest
problem we have right now is
everything's very dark right like I tend
to work dark anyways
on a lot of projects but this is really
dark so one thing I need to try and do
is change the texture I so I changed it
to white and it made it red right so I
don't necessarily want that I could try
and bring down the white levels here a
little bit dark like that but the the
overall this is just way if I bring this
so if I bring it up like this a little
bit brighter
I like that okay I don't want it to be a
hundred percent black a lot of times I
do like more like the bluish blacks
which this is a little too much but
that's kind of nice right in there so I
read as I selected a blue shade here and
I went below that's at zero and I just
kind of brought up into some of the blue
tones something maybe like that and that
seems to work okay just like that type
again go back to white just to see yeah
it's too bright but then this is maybe a
little bit too hard to read so maybe
something like that I also you know
everyone's whole just play around with
like just no trying some different
colors here but I don't know that works
Beckett so now I'll do is a look at the
different scenes yeah it's looking
pretty cool I'm like I said Nina this
works so what color is this oh I'd go in
here I'd select this I ctrl C to copy or
her to Gina and I ctrl V to paste and I
come to Toby again I would paste and
looking a little bit dark like I said
now when this flicker comes in it's
really powerful so it might take it
above here and just see yeah so bring in
the flicker to the very top seems to
work a little better now there it's too
much one thing you can try is switch
from normal mode to overlay and let's
just see what that sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't it's a lot more
subtle so now maybe bring up the opacity
and I'm just previewing a small section
here just to see if what I'm trying is
working versus proving the entire thing
so I really kind of works let's see what
softlight does here that's okay that's a
little bit more aggressive that's pretty
cool I don't know what these white lines
are here I think that maybe that is the
wave warp so if I pin the edges boom
it's gone and this is just something
that you learn over time like with
certain effects have some weird things
they do
there was another weird thing right here
so this could be the background so if I
was to try and scale up the background
here let's see no that's not gonna do it
maybe the gradient background texture I
think that might be the culprit here so
if I scale it up a little bit no that's
not it either
so it's something to do with this glitch
so if we wrapped pickles pixels around
there we go again so I'll probably need
to select these I need to wrap these
pixels around not sure why it's on this
side here like that fix that and let's
wrap these pixels around again
maybe stretch the map or tile the map
that's interesting I saw it popping over
here like that hmm
oh no no what's going on with that some
kind of figure that out what's creating
what I don't know what that I'm just
talking to myself here
what is that so it's something to do
with the background so I scaled the
background it seems to have gotten rid
of it so works for me you could see when
we added the duotone effect as well
before we had that we had this grid wall
that if I solo it was all these
different colors and now it obviously
blends in more with the entire piece
looking at this
yes I'm I am moving kind of quick here
I'm gonna bring some hacker text into
this shot here and I have to find it
where let's make it let's make it white
let's make this one white as well make
sure this is white and I don't know they
are there let's have them ignore the
light so right now let's turn to accept
lights on if I hit this to off there
they go so they're there now and they're
very subtle
I don't want them huge on the screen I
do want to be able to see them so let's
just try maybe like a purple what does
that do that does not work for me so
very subtle there there by hit B and
preview this yeah you can see them
that's pretty cool
and maybe I'll just duplicate them and
they should get a little bit brighter so
you saw they got a little bit brighter
there and I actually really like that
glitchy effect on this one so maybe what
I'll do is I'll have it go across the
entire thing and I'll set it hold
keyframe again which is right click hold
keyframe and then I hop in maybe around
here it goes away and then it can do
something where it kind of just pops off
and on
you know that's pretty cool okay okay so
there we go it's getting real close and
you can see that we've come a long ways
again by just adding a few different
elements here one thing that feels off
so I love I absolutely love this which
is something just you know happen to
fall into so now it makes this look too
crystal clear so what I'm gonna do here
is and when I say crystal clear I mean
like the type here right everything else
in this piece or in this composition in
this scene is a little bit it's textured
is corrupt its digitized and Nina gates
is not okay so I'm just gonna do the
same thing here I'm just going to
stretch this out I'm gonna add a hold
keyframe at 100% and then when we get
here we're just gonna drop it down so
something really low like 11 percent and
you can see it's creating like this
reflection down here which is pretty
cool bump it up
and I want to be readable
yeah that's pretty cool and then we'll
do the same thing here but for this one
I think we're just gonna duplicate this
glitch layer and have it just pop on
here and make sure it references itself
there we go and for the transparency I'm
just going to bring it down yeah that
works for me so there he goes so one
last thing we could do I really dig what
this is looking like I'm just saved it
there but one thing I did in the
original when I was building out this
idea is I added what I call like a VHS
retro look to it which is I gave it a
lot of noise disintegrate more like
disruptive effects corruptive effects I
guess I don't know the right word for it
but I get tongue-tied sometimes with I
don't use the proper words my wife gives
me a hard time about it but that's okay
hopefully you get the idea
so if I was to do that let me save this
I'm gonna add one more adjustment layer
and this is just gonna be called effects
but what I would do for a final kind of
pass on this is use a sapphire effect
again like I said there's a lot of
effects that do this this type of thing
there's one in sapphire called warp
chroma and obviously that's way too much
that you see there I'm gonna let this
preset load but red-giant creates a warp
chrome effect
it's chromatic aberration is essentially
what it is there's I don't know there's
probably ten other companies out there
to create a chromatic effect it's a very
very subtle I'm gonna load this if you
don't have third-party plugins
I definitely invite you to check out my
profile you can do a chromatic
aberration without plugins it's really
easy to do it's just a few extra steps
so that's with bats without very very
very subtle but it's the subtleties that
all the details are all the difference
for final polish projects next I would
go into color correction I would add
curves and I would do something here
where I add three points I would bring
down my whites really crush them like
that and bring up the blacks and this is
something done the original actually
don't love it as much here that actually
works right there so I brought up the
blacks a little bit I'm also going to
add some noise and grain and we're gonna
do noise instead of grain we're just
gonna add it what ten percent or so and
I don't know how much this you can see
but it just adds a little bit extra to
it it looks really nice and then I could
go back into my blur and sharpen a fast
box blur and just a blur radius of two
to kind of blur it repeat edge pixels
and then I'm gonna go in and I'm going
to sharpen the crap out of it
so I'll pump this up to like 250 and
yeah you know what looking at this I
don't think those are necessary so I
really like that a lot so let me preview
this and let's see we wrap
[Music]
so that looks really cool to me it looks
kind of like modern futuristic just to
show you something here if you were to
change this for like the flicker from
soft light to something like color burn
it completely changes the mood here so
if I turn off the audio so I can talk
over this it completely changes the mood
- this is something much more almost
like dark and sinister very very dark so
the type is really easy to read right
but it's almost it took on a whole
different vibe to me almost like a
horror film just by changing the flicker
from soft light to color burn right so
here's back to color burn or soft light
I'm kind of modern purple red like I see
that a lot with like I don't know movies
like Blade Runner and things like that I
kind of that color palette so from from
more futuristic modern to dark and you
know kind of like a horror field so I
like actually both of them a lot I'll
probably change it back to soft light
just for this example and to finish this
off there's always you know things
there's additional things you can always
do but I don't want to take up too much
your time
the final thing I'd do is I would
probably just add a letterbox because
this is more of a kind of a cinematic
looking piece and there's a thousand
different ways you can do this but you
know I'm not going to be super way out
here I'm not going to be super exact
here with what you have to have so
because this is not going to some
theater release or anything like that
it's not going on TV it's not you know
anything like that I just added a mask
and subtract lock the layer turn off my
guides and now we've got more of a
cinematic letterboxed piece so that's it
that's what I wanted to teach you guys
in these three parts so I constantly get
asked or get told by designers like oh
well you can't it's it's so challenging
to become a designer in terms of motion
graphics I see so many motion designers
motion graphic artists immediately go
into animation and they get really good
at animation but they don't know how to
design anything they don't know how to
put pieces together compositionally to
make them look good and I wanted to show
you right here in this three-part series
we didn't take very much time at all and
we put together a really nice looking
title sequence motion tests for a
potential project so it is not hard to
design inside of motion design you just
have to know how to approach it
and I am going to in the next video talk
to you guys about my program called
style craft and if you haven't heard a
style craft it's a year-long
mentorship and training program where I
teach you this I teach you exactly how
to design inside of After Effects inside
of cinema 4d and how to become a true
motion designer it's not about animation
it does teach you some animation skills
of course I mean that's very important
but it really focuses in on how to how
to design your pieces how to start from
ideas and get to execution how to make
your pieces look exceptionally well
because there there is a a lot of motion
designers out there in the world today
that don't know how to make
well-designed pieces and they see
animation I see on Instagram all the
time I see someone because of this you
know how to make someone dance or do
something and then you see everyone else
do the same thing and then okay look at
what I did that's great but to be a true
motion designer you have to know how to
take different projects and and really
break them apart and figure out how to
create those so like I said I'm going to
talk to you in the next video about my
program called style craft the
registration is opening up really really
quickly depending on when you're
watching this it may have already opened
so that's what I've got for you today I
hope you really enjoyed this three-part
series I want to see what you come up
with based on what you've learned
like I said it's actually quite simple
if you know the techniques in the
workflows to get from idea to execution
with a piece at your problem so again
I'm going to be opening up style craft
very soon in the meantime please leave
me a comment or a question below let me
know what you guys think if you learn
something new if you've made something
post it share it with the group let's
see what you come up with so until next
time thanks so much for for being here
I'm Cameron and this is motion science